This is absolutely fascinating and infuriating.
And I want to be super careful here to ensure
that I'm not violating any guidelines on any
of our platforms.
We finally found one example of what the right
has been calling dead people voting.
And of course, it wasn't a dead person.
It was a live person doing something illegal.
A pro Trump, Pennsylvania man has been charged
with voter fraud for casting a ballot for
Donald Trump under his dead mother's name.
I'm going to get into the details in a moment.
But remember, the voter fraud Trump crowd
for seven weeks now has been saying hundreds
of thousands of dead people voted for Joe
Biden in the 2012 election.
In some cases, they say tens of thousands.
When this was investigated, it turned out
that it happened essentially.
Not at all.
Most of the people listed as dead in, I believe
it was in Michigan were just alive.
I mean, that that's really they were people
who did vote, but they're alive.
They're not dead.
Others were registered.
They died since registering and they didn't
vote.
So in other words, they showed up as registered
because they were but they died and didn't
vote because dead people can't vote, as some
others were.
Name confusion, a junior voting, and then
it being counted as their dad's vote senior
who has passed away.
But it was still only one vote counted.
It wasn't it being counted twice for one person.
It's a clerical error.
And of course, the implication always was
that this was part of a scam to help Joe Biden
steal the election, another claim they didn't
have any evidence for.
Aside from the fact that it's really a bad
strategy to steal an election.
It's so much work for one vote in this way.
But we finally found out that somebody did
do this.
And it is a 70 year old man named Bruce Bertman
in Pennsylvania who registered his dead mother
and his dead mother in law to vote using the
online registration portal, registered them
both as Republicans requested absentee ballots
in their names and returned one of the absentee
ballots for his deceased mother.
Voting for Trump.
He's confessed.
He made a statement to the DA's office saying
he cast a vote for his in the name of his
dead mother for Donald Trump.
And there are many takeaways here.
First of all, the claim from the Trump is
that this is widespread is a fantasy.
Pennsylvania received hundreds of tips about
supposedly dead voters.
They followed up on all of them and they found
one and the guy voted for Trump.
OK, number two, the story from the right is
always that it's Democrats doing the voter
fraud.
And yet every time it's investigated, every
election, it's a handful of Republicans doing
it.
There was a similar story back in 2016, maybe
2018, maybe both.
There were scary generalizations about voter
fraud.
But when we found the few instances of people
doing it earnestly, it was Republicans.
We found instances of Republicans testing
the system, trying to vote twice, and they
got caught.
And once again here, 70 year old Republican
caught submitting a ballot for Trump in the
name of his dead mother.
One other Republican in Pennsylvania was also
charged for casting a ballot in person, went
home, put on sunglasses, went back to the
polling place and claimed to be his own son
to vote a second time.
He's also been caught and charged.
So, again, no evidence of materially relevant
voter fraud.
But these two guys accused of individual fraud,
which, of course, would not have affected
the Pennsylvania results.
Either way, Joe Biden won by seventy one thousand
votes.
But the two instances where people voting
for Trump anyway, so it only took seven weeks,
but we finally found one supposedly dead voter
and it was a Trump vote anyway.
So do not fall for this stuff, my friends.
It really will rot your brain.
We have real problems to deal with in this
country.
We have real election problems and they include
some.
And closing of polling places, disenfranchisement
of different kinds.
We have a long list of dead people voting,
not a problem.
One guy did it.
He got caught in Pennsylvania.
Remember that on January one, we are blowing
out membership's before Joe Biden comes into
office and says, David, 70 percent membership
discounts are no longer allowed.
That's a joke, by the way.
But we really are doing a one day membership
special, January 1st, 2021, if you would like
to be notified about it.
This is very simple.
You go to David Pakman Dotcom upper right
of the website.
You type in your email address, puts you on
our newsletter.
January 1st, you'll get an email telling you
how to sign up, taking advantage of this great
membership special.
Let me know what you think about the voter
fraud story from Pennsylvania.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.